[Musique]
une batterie recouverte de poils une
danse hypnotique en veste rose un autre
monde imaginé par l'artiste lorente
rochelle il ya quelque chose qui renvoie
une sorte d'animal qu'on serait en train
de rentrer en train d'opérer et donc ces
instruments étaient transformés avec de
la fourrure et puis ils sont augmentés
de
voilà ils sont mécanisées il ya quelque
chose qui m'intrigue qui m'intéressent
qui m'amuse dont j'essaie de rendre
compte de manière poétique au coeur de
la chapelle de la commanderie des
templiers
l'exposition se veut un spectacle
permanent un laboratoire d'expériences
des créations réalisées spécialement en
harmonie avec le lieu
c'est un lieu qui me touchent et j'avais
envie
d'abord que
ce que j montrait
entre en résonance est en relation avec
ce lieu est en même temps le laisse le
laisse visible je n'avais pas envie de
le masquer ou de de mettre trop de
choses qui voilà qui aurait
ray fait qu'on ne verrait plus la
chapelle une rencontre entre sciences de
l'ingénieur et création artistique à
découvrir jusqu en juillet et pour les
plus patients un message en morse et de
déchiffrer dans le rythme de la bâtisse
[Musique]